du sac et dans le pastis cette semaine à
marseille mais a priori ne s'agit pas de
commerce
contrairement au forum des halles qui
vient d'être racheté en partie par les
japonais la canebière et le vieux-port
ne sont pas encore avancé ce qu'on dit
officiellement il s'agit donc d'une
semaine culturelle japonaise sans
arrière pensées mercantiles à marseille
patrice bellet et jean-françois jour j
si marseille était une île pour une
semaine elle serait japonaise prière au
dieu de la montagne pour gagner la
guerre la danse des samouraïs
ils viennent de neg ata au nord du japon
mais c'est plus impressionnant de les
renvoyer à l'acte et jaffe martiaux qui
est haché d'agréable à regarder c'est
déjà par leur philosophie tout ça qui
gagne à être de dire les japonais on les
connaît surtout avec la leur tour leurs
produits quoi tout ça alors ça change un
peu de voir le japon ancien japon
millénaire s'il manquait une culture à
la mosaïque marseillaise ce serait sans
doute la japonaise l'art du soleil
levant un art de vivre ancestral
recettes pour supporter la modernité
échevelé il s'entraîne très durement
il gagne la vie autrement c'est à dire
ils sont salariés ils sont paysans et
cetera mais ils ont toujours grand envie
de montrer la à la technique
donc ce n'est pas pour préparer de
bonnes affaires avec les français
ensuite pour aucun rapport ankara pas en
touriste en saltimbanque mais surtout
pas en acheteurs les japonais
le vieux port ne sera donc pas vendue
pour quelques milliards de yens la bonne
affaire de la semaine à marseille ne
sera qu'une histoire de culture